joining me today is a professor of
English at the University of Ottawa an
author a self-declared anti-feminist and
a campaigner for the right to dissent
Janus V mango welcome to the Reuben
report well thank you very much Dave
it's nice to have you here we were
looped in by this Jordan Peterson fella
apparently everyone knows this guy now
so before we do anything else I thought
it would be interesting since he looped
us in together what do you make of the
Jordan Peterson phenomenon well to say
the very least I think what Jordan
proves is that there is an incredible
hunger out there amongst young people
maybe amongst young men in particular
but obviously amongst women as well for
for for something that's really genuine
and hard-hitting and real in terms of
discussing what matters in the world
today something that we aren't getting
in our public conversations at all and
and Jordan obviously offers that and and
all of the attempts to discredit him and
to claim that he represents something
really dark and nefarious it clearly
isn't working and turning people off
yeah it ain't gonna stop though no no it
no it's just ramping up I think yeah
yeah what is going on in Canada that
there seems to be a burst of Canadian
professors from from Jordan to you and
GAD sad sad and plenty of others feel
free to name-drop some others that
should be on my radar there seems to be
a real pushback from Canadian professors
at least a small select group of them
against this sort of groupthink and Pro
faux diversity and whatever you want to
call this whole movement yeah well um
actually I think it's unfortunately
still a relatively small group I would
say I think there needs to be a lot more
in the way of pushback the thing that
really struck me about Jordan Peterson
the situation when he
you know first sort of burst onto the
scene with his declaration that he would
not you know he would not engage in
forced speech that that not a single
professor at the University of Toronto
would come forward even to say I may not
necessarily agree with what he's saying
but I support his right to say it and
that's one of the largest universities
if not the largest university in Canada
and probably the most prestigious one
and the fact that not a single professor
felt that he or she could stand with
Jordan in that moment that was
astounding to me and so yeah there are a
few and GAD sat is a wonderful example I
have a close friend at Acadia University
who was actually just fired this year
Rick Mehta
yeah who was inspired by Jordan he he
was someone who had been thinking for
years a lot of the things that Jordan
has talked about in terms of the
groupthink in academia the whole range
of subjects that you can't even talk
about well that you can't talk about
from a variety of positions that you
have to take one position on and so he
finally started speaking out before this
he was an award-winning teacher and the
year he started speaking out he had so
many complaints and he's now actually
been fired a tenured professor this is
an astounding thing so so unfortunately
I would say that what's happening in
Canada is that a few people are speaking
out and a lot of people are speaking
privately saying you know I really
support what you're talking about and I
really wish I could do it as well but
it's way too dangerous for me to do so
and the case of Professor Mehta at
Acadia proves that indeed people have
reason to be very fearful yeah you know
in the case of professor Mehta it's so
interesting to me that one of the ways I
get guests is that suddenly someone does
something often at a university and then
it starts bubbling and there's some
stories written and then I start hearing
about it on Twitter and then it bubbles
up enough and then they usually end up
right in that seat where you are right
there
I suspect he'll probably be in here -
and in a weird way all of you guys are
just defending the ability to think
about these issues yeah the positions
that most of you are taking often
wouldn't have been considered radical 20
years absolutely not no no they wouldn't
have been it in fact I mean in in
professor metas case it seems to me he's
such an excellent example of the fact
that this is not about even an
individual saying offensive things
because what were the supposed defensive
well I mean like and he didn't take
these as positions you know he he I
think would would identify himself as a
classic liberal he's not particularly
conservative but he he wanted to talk
about the full range of issues he
objected to his universities indigenous
a ssin program which I think maybe was
the most controversial of the subjects
and this is I think this is probably now
the top hot-button issue at Canadian
universities it's the the move to
replace European based knowledge as
exclusionary and inadequate and
subjective and to replace it in some
cases with indigenous knowledge even in
something called indigenous science
which many scientists would say is
actually not I mean there is only
there's science that is all there is and
so indigenous science has to do with
indigenous ways of knowing elders
knowledge what some might say is
superstition or magical beliefs of sort
of anecdotal kinds of observations and
you know there's an attempt on the part
of universities in some ways a lot of a
one to bring in indigenous peoples
who've been excluded from the university
experience for many years for a variety
of reasons but the idea that indigenous
knowledge is not to be questioned that
it has a value equal to supposedly
Europeans
science is a really incredibly worrisome
and strange idea and so he objected to
that and he raised a whole bunch of
other questions not even saying that he
wanted to that he was necessarily taking
a position on them but merely saying
that you know he said that identity
politics is divisive and causes
resentment what I thought can you
believe it yeah never heard that before
yeah he talked about you know the the
the psychological science about
differences in in preference and
interest and intellectual ability
between men and women he what else did
he he talked about the wage gap and and
said that you know that there was a lot
of evidence to suggest that it was based
on preferences and choices that people
made rather than bias against women
they're a whole bunch of I mean he
really was just trying to do what
exactly as you said professors once were
supposed to do and that's now no longer
possible in in the university classroom
and I think a lot of students probably
liked him I mean he got these teaching
awards and he had a lot of support even
up until the point that he was fired but
because I a cadre of very angry students
and also very angry colleagues and it is
often professors who are persecuting
other professors they claimed a
complaint about him and said that he was
you know harassing them so let's put the
student part aside for a second because
we're gonna get to that a little bit but
the the colleague hmm the fact that so
much of this is being driven by other
professors I mean we saw this with Brad
Weinstein in Evergreen State Jordan and
many of my other friends who are
professors now tell me they often get
support privately from professors but
not publicly which is the most enraging
GAD tells me about this all the time but
what do you make of professors that are
that are leading this with the charge
against inquiry and and thought mmm-hmm
well they're true believers I think many
of them and well though some are true
believers they they see themselves as
part of a revolution that's absolutely
necessary they believe that
our society is one of entrenched
inequality and structural violence
against women against racial minorities
against indigenous peoples against trans
people and you know you know that all
the the the claims and and so they they
see that any attempt to argue or against
their positions or to simply call for
more open discussion is a way of
reasserting a very unjust they would say
you know deathly status quo and then a
lot of people I think are not true
believers but are just going along for
career reasons or because it's easier to
go along they just want to do their
research and they can only do it in
peace if they say all the correct
you know platitudes so I mean I'm what
happened was that I think gradually the
idea of the university was destroyed it
whenever it started how it happened and
it seems to have started sometimes in
the late 60s Allan bloom I'm sure you've
read the closing of the American mind
you know he is claimed is that
professors lost faith in the idea of the
University as a sort of separate space
where you you simply thought about
things you didn't get involved and I he
has a wonderful line I remember
something about how Socrates felt that
it was more important to think about
justice and to you know to really learn
what justice is rather than try to
implement whatever partial version of it
you know is roiling the public
consciousness of the day and and so that
was what the university had meant that
it's best I think right so the way this
is a case of where the University
original mission of being a place to
find truth and giving people the
opportunity to think about these issues
debate these issues etc has taken a
complete 180 because now it seems to be
the breeding ground for the opposite of
those ideas it is a breeding ground for
sure I mean it's it's where all of the
indoctrination takes place and then of
course the the students who are
indoctrinated go out into all
major spheres of our society they they
go to law school where they they read
critical legal theory that tells them
that there there is there's nothing
unbiased or objective about the legal
system that we have in North America
that it needs to be completely remade
they become journalists and they go to
journalism school where they learn the
same thing and they're told that a
journalist should be somebody who
attempts to improve and change society
make it better rather than just report
that you know what's what's happening
they become teachers they they go into
the education faculties where they're
also being radicalized and you know and
and so it's not surprising that this is
where we're at now one of the things
that fascinates me about this every time
I hear another professor come in and
talk about it all right to see another
breaking story about it or another
monument taken down or whatever it is
this is nature of history yeah is that
what you said before about the the
indigenous sciences it's like they don't
want you to just say okay maybe we could
have an extra course in this and teach
it hopefully with the same academic
rigor as you would teach European
sciences or what's known as you said as
science we could have a parallel course
if you want to take that as well but
they actually they want to replace
history and that that seems to me to be
the most dangerous part of this yeah
yeah well it and begin it but it's not
surprising if you believe that the
system that we have now is you know
kills people it's always the rhetoric is
really really extreme it's like you know
what you're saying is is violence to me
and my family what you're saying you
know causes people to die so if you
really believe that in some way then you
can't just bring in you can't just have
add-ons of other courses it is that this
is not a rumor in the witches yeah
absolutely it's this and it's not a
reform movement even where you could get
to a point where you would say okay
we've made you know certain structural
changes to satisfy you know these
various concerns it is a radical
revolutionary movement that everything
has to be smashed
and rebuilt and and yeah and and I think
there's a very naive confidence on the
part of many professors that that they
know better than generations and
generations of people who came before
and they will be able to build Jerusalem
I somehow it's somehow doubted all right
but so let's back up a little bit and
get to your involvement in all of this
so a self-declared anti-feminist the
defender of dissent of a big fan of
dissent so just tell me a little bit
about your academic background and what
sort of brought you to believe some of
the things that you believe now yeah
well you know I started off as I think a
pretty well to go back further I started
off as just a you know someone who loved
literature I was a nerd I loved to read
and that was all I you know from the
time I was very young I wanted to be a
university professor I want to teach
literature so then I got into graduate
school and I was radicalized there I
would say like everyone you know and and
and and that experience was really
important to me in that I realized how
incredibly pleasurable it is to be a
radical yeah you know you describe that
a little bit that feeling rock we're
getting slammed with now yeah it's you
know it's it's very addictive and maybe
it is even a kind of addiction I'm sure
that there are all sorts of chemical
changes that go on in your brain when
you're feeling this this it's a
combination of sort of euphoric rage and
self-righteous indignation and and and
and righteous outrage and so yeah I'd
you know I did all the things I marched
and Take Back the Night marches and I
worked at a women's shelter and and
suddenly then I started to see that my
purpose in becoming a university
professor would be to radicalize other
students and to show them what I had
come to understand
and yeah and it's it's a it's a very
heady experience and I've thought for
years and years like then I came off it
because I think partly because of my
background my parents are lower middle
class and my dad died last year but
somehow the that outrage it just didn't
fit with the values that they've given
me and did it I couldn't hold on to the
the conviction how long did it last for
you it lasted while I was a graduate
student really so like from my about in
1991 to 94 or something around there and
then it started to fade off yes you
remember do you remember moments was
there seminal moment there wasn't one
moment I wouldn't say but there there
were just there were a number of moments
where I I just I couldn't hold on to the
sense of conviction I can't think of a
specific moment until like by the time I
started teaching full-time I started
teaching full-time in 1999 and at that
point I would have said that I was I
probably would have said I was still a
feminist but I would have seen myself as
more of a moderate feminist and and and
I wouldn't that wouldn't have been my
primary self-identification I would have
said I was an animal lover you know or
something else like that and then but
9/11 was really my that was my moment
and it was because at the university
that I was teaching out at the time
University of Saskatchewan I'll never
forget that morning I was already at
work the secretary said that you know
planes had flown into the the towers and
I you know I was horrified and and but I
noticed that the mood at the University
and in my department in particular it
was one of like barely contained sort of
vaunting pleasure Wow
I couldn't believe it and or at least I
mean maybe that's you know maybe not
everybody felt that that
could have been just my my sense of it
but certainly a kind of satisfaction and
in fact one of my friends came into the
mailroom and said well they've got what
they deserved
this is like you know within an hour of
the news another said that she was going
to teach about it that day and this was
like really early on in the term so she
hadn't even really started I think this
was like our first week probably yeah
first week or maybe the the first part
of the second week but anyway and she
was gonna teach about the event and she
was going to talk about how how this
would be used by reaction how this would
likely be used by reactionary forces in
the United States and how it'd be very
interesting to watch over the next few
days who they would blame and how they
would begin to manipulate I thought wow
like it hasn't I mean you know it she
never even thought that maybe there
would be students in the class who would
be really upset I might even you don't
know somebody who knew somebody or it
was just the the lack of human empathy
and the the hatred the satisfied hatred
that that was really my moment that
turned me off completely from everything
to do with the the left progressivism
the anti Americanism the anti Western
culture everything then the other thing
that was happening at the same time role
in the year before too was that my
department was doing a fair bit of
hiring and we were doing what we called
equity hiring affirmative action hiring
and we were very very keen to hire more
women and to hire members of visible
minorities and indigenous people and I I
just you know and there was you weren't
allowed to obviously object in any way
and nobody did everyone this that maybe
occasionally privately a bit a bit of
Demuro but but basically everyone was
publicly very enthusiastic and it just
struck me as the most unjust ridiculous
thing I'm basically like no men no white
men were were even considered for any of
the positions that were offered and I I
I couldn't see how that was a good thing
in any way at all and it just it seemed
to me out raging and that all and you
know we would get hundreds of
applications for some of the positions
and all of these men who'd done all
these amazing things being just being
put aside and women who had done far far
less being considered and brought in for
interview and always the idea was that
you know this was equity hiring which
meant that if two candidates were
equally qualified and you know we would
choose the woman but of course as soon
as you're looking to hire right
political reason you're not considering
the true qualities of the candidates at
all so in in a situation like this if we
if you had two candidates that had the
exact same criteria and you had a
department that was say 90% male mm-hmm
in that case what would your position be
on this if they truly I know what you're
saying
never get to that place where it's
exactly what the proposition is yeah no
they aren't there are never two
candidates who are exactly the same and
I honestly could never see a situation
where it would be so urgent that you
would hire on the basis of you know an
identity category III can't believe that
I mean the arguments for changing the
you know the demographic mix of
workplaces or whatever I can see them
applying in in very narrow circumstances
for instance in primary school I would
say yeah it's probably a good idea that
children have a mix of men and women and
as teacher
and and maybe even an ethnic mix if it's
a ethnically mixed school I could see
that as important and for in fact that
doesn't happen because you know most
primary schools are taught almost
entirely by by women so little boys who
might not have a dad at home are not
even getting a chance to have a male
role model male role model at primary
school so that would be a place where I
could maybe see the case for it but at a
university I just I really can't see the
necessity I don't believe that any
promising young person is actually going
to be turned off a subject because they
don't see somebody who looks exactly
like them reflected in the prophets
aureate and if they do then what a
deeply profound disturbance has already
happened yeah education system right
yeah I mean I just I mean I don't
believe that our system is is so
exclusionary and you know that I mean we
hear this so much about how now
especially women in stem and and also I
guess racial minorities but but I hear
more about women you know they just
can't go into astronomy because
supposedly there aren't enough female
astronomers a friend of mine who
actually left Australia he was working
as an astrophysicist in Australia he
left there and went to China because he
realized that there was no future for
him at all like no he couldn't possibly
get a tenure-track position because they
were so set on hiring women or other
identity categories and he always sends
me things and recently he sent me
something a PhD student was being
brought in to talk to I think his old
Department she said I'm so glad I'm not
there anymore and and she was going to
be talking about how you know they're
all there are not enough women
represented in astronomy because even
like the laws are named after they're
all named after
men there's a Newton's law you know soon
enough
yeah and that was the idea that some of
these laws should actually be named
after somebody else even though they're
named after the men because the men
obviously were the ones that discovered
the laws yeah I mean it's just it's
ludicrous they could try to make their
own discoveries after themselves
regardless I think because they're just
so you know so beaten down by the
oppressive maleness of the discipline
and it's just it isn't true it's not
true I mean I could see if you know male
professors were standing up telling
these female students up you're never
gonna you know you don't have the right
brain for it or whatever well that would
be tempered but nobody is doing that
nobody's doing that you know professors
are delighted to have anyone who's
promising and capable male or female or
whatever color their skin is it just
isn't the case that there are all these
you know systemic barriers to
participation so so when you had these
two experiences so so 9/11 and then the
hiring yeah what I find often and I
think it sort of happened to me is once
you have your little wake up about what
this sort of unending monster on the
left is everything else collapses pretty
quickly so how does how did that
collapse if the rest of the collapse was
pretty quick how did that lead you to
where now you're so outspoken about
feminism and a series of other issues
yeah well it just it did everything else
did collapse pretty quickly and and and
what I became especially upset about was
was the what I came to see as the really
negative environment for for young men
at university because I I began thinking
about what it must feel like to sit
there day after day after day hearing
about how all the good things in the
world are the contribution of women and
all the bad things are the contribution
of men and how what young men have to do
today is basically just take a step back
step away from the power as Professor
Susana Walters said in
that Washington Post piece why can't we
hate men you know that's what you have
to do as a man you have to bear the
weight of centuries of male privilege
and oppressive behavior and so you just
have to step back don't run for office
don't do anything I mean you know as if
I mean it's unbelievable bow yes
basically yeah and yeah be object
apologize for your so-called privilege
and let your sisters come forward and
make the world a better place and and
that is I mean that it's so crude and so
ridiculous but I don't think it's an
exaggeration to say that that is the
message that most young men are getting
at university today that the only way to
be a good man is to focus all of your
energy and attention on someone else
whether it's oh you know on helping
women or in helping the indigenous or
whatever it happens to be that you can't
have your own concerns you can't have
your own needs and you certainly can't
have your own problems or issues that's
the only way you can be a good person so
yeah it just seemed to me outrageous and
I kept waiting for other people like to
say something about it and I would
occasionally talk to others about it so
yeah they could sort of see but they
know they weren't willing to stick their
necks out in any way and so finally I
just got to the point where I thought
well I I should do it that isn't that a
weird position to be in because I do
find so many of the people that I've
talked to that have had similar
evolutions to you they don't think of
themselves as particularly brave or
particularly like oh I was the one that
wanted to save the world or anything it
but you get pushed to a point where then
finally you're at that ledge and it's
either they're gonna push you over and
you'll never speak again and they'll
disappear or you kind of turn around and
fight back yeah I mean in my case I
especially I it's not that I don't I
because I do get a rash out of conflict
and that sort of thing but for this
particular issue I don't think I'm very
good at it I mean for one thing it it's
very difficult to be on the other side
of a social justice issue because
to be on the right side the left side
you yeah the correct side I should say
the left side it's easy because you hear
the arguments over and over again so you
know you just you know we just have to
open your mouth and they all come and
and usually people are stunned into
embarrassed silence as soon as you start
attacking them with your various claims
and your various charges against them
but to be able to argue really
effectively on the other side you not
only have to know the the all the left
side arguments but then you have to you
know research all all these things that
you've been taught we're simply not true
or we're unthinkable or you know we're
impossible and yeah it's not about my
area of expertise certainly you know my
area of expertise is literature but and
I don't think I'm very good like you
have to be good in debate and you know
answering people's challenging questions
and I hate all that I'm terrible at that
but but and so if there were I'd mess
you've got yeah and I didn't really you
know and I I didn't entirely understand
what it would be like like when I gave
my first couple of talks and they were
protested and they pulled the fire
alarms and there were a lot of really
angry students in the audience I really
had no idea that it was gonna be like
that I thought it was just gonna I was
sort of going to talk about academic
feminism in a sort of bounded way and I
knew that because I'd studied it for
years but I didn't realize I was gonna
be asked to answer questions about you
know everything to do with the relations
between men and women and you know rape
and all of these big issues so I didn't
do a very good job I didn't think but
but you know nobody else is is doing it
and so I want to keep on and I started
doing my video series three years ago
and and that has given me a lot of
satisfaction actually because well as
soon as I started speaking in public I
got a lot of emails an incredible number
of emails mostly from young men some
from men
that young talking about their
experiences and they blew me away that
the and I know Jordans talked about this
too but the the amount of pain that
there is out there
the number of young men who just want to
they love women in most cases they want
to have a happy relationship
they've never intended to hurt or
oppress anyone and yet they're told that
even without intending to they do just
by looking at a young woman you know or
asking her out on a date they're doing
some sort of violence and the pain that
that has caused and the uncertainty and
the confusion and the resentment as well
it's you know and some of these young
men have themselves been abused their
parents sometimes their mothers have
been abusive or girlfriends and yet
they're in you know they have to hear
over and over again about how it's only
men who are ever abusive and yeah it's
it's amazing to me like once you go into
down the rabbit hole or whatever it is
and you see the the our culture from the
other side and every time you turn on
the news there's yet another story about
you know whatever the terrible problem
of cat calling and how it represents you
know the the deep misogyny of North
American culture and what needs to be
done about it and you know all that kind
of thing yeah it's it's astounding so so
now I sort of feel like with my videos
anyway that my my role is to at least to
say to young men that you're not crazy
our culture is is actually crazy alright
so let's talk about this crisis in
masculinity is that is that the right
way to phrase it do you think these sure
yeah that's fine yeah that'll work
okay that there do seem to be so many
men who as you said they don't hate
women yeah they they they don't hate
themselves they don't they but they're
sort of wounded and
fuse yeah I see these people often at
Jordan's shows and I don't even mean
that that shows are filled with these
people there's just people that are kind
of confused their roadmap is a little
screwed up and he's kind of helping them
get back on the road I don't he doesn't
even talk about gender that often or any
of that stuff but whatever reason his
broader message of clean up your room
get your stuff together fix yourself
before you fix the world yeah that seems
to be a message that these people are
hearing yeah this crisis are you able to
really figure out how widespread it is I
mean I know you're getting you're
getting sort of emails and you're
putting up your video series and all
that but like can you really tell like
how much of this has just sort of gone
across culture because it does seem to
sort of be them the beginnings of the
next culture war yeah I mean I yeah it's
it's hard to say exactly I mean
certainly at the University there's been
a tremendous decline in men attending
that women now dominate in numbers at
pretty well know every university at
least in North America and I assume it's
true in Western Europe as well now there
might be lots of reasons for that but
one has to assume that at least a part
of the reason is that men feel that
there isn't a place for them at the
university and at the relentless man
blaming and man shaming that goes on
there has got to have something to do
with that I would think and there are a
number of reports certainly that I've
read recently indicate that in a whole
bunch of other ways men are just not
doing very well generally either there
was a report that came out a few years
ago called wayward sons it came out of
MIT to economists talking about how in a
number of different metrics whether it
was skills acquisition real wages
there's just employment numbers job
status men are falling behind women
really shockingly and and then that's
leading into all sorts of other social
problems two men are not getting married
because they're not in a position to be
able to support a family there are many
other reasons why men are not getting
married as well and so then that means
that more and more women are are raising
their children outside of marriage and
and then that often has very bad impacts
for the boys in those single mom
situations they they tend to be the ones
that are hurt most by the lack of a
father and and so yeah that it certainly
seems that there's some pretty
widespread problems suicide male suicide
is something that a lot of people that I
work with are very concerned about
mental illness what they call failure to
launch meaning just a lot of young men's
feeling that there isn't anything for
them in society and so why even try to
contribute anything to it at all it does
seem to be a pretty widespread problem
from what people like Warren Farrell who
studied the subject for years certainly
and of course christina hoff sommers as
well yeah what are the tactics that
you've seen work effectively to if
someone contacts you and you know
they're they're feeling all of the
things that you've discussed they're not
feeling what they're experienced yeah do
you have a sort of groundwork for how
they can kind of get their lives in
order and fight some of this it's really
just you're just making them aware yeah
I mean I befriend them and and and I I
tell them that what they're feeling has
a real basis I mean that part of the
problem is that they're told that they
they're their only problem is a sense of
entitlement you know which is the last
thing that's true about men's experience
today so part of the thing is that I
mean I think many of the young men that
write to me it's not that they
necessarily think they're the biggest
victims in the world it's that there is
not even a smidgen of a
Berenice that they would ever have
anything to worry about
the sense that you know everything that
they have it's because they're so
privileged so in the weird ways this and
through that lens it's like society you
should have everything you should feel
great look you've been handed everything
mhm but then society is continually
making you feel like crap
yeah which is like a completely
double-edged sword because you're
supposed to feel great you feel like
crap they're never giving you a chance
to feel good because there's nothing you
can do
yeah get yourself out of this yeah and
it's it's I mean I I think it's a it is
a devastating social problem and again
yeah I don't know the exact extent of
the problem but from what people who
know and who've studied it more
certainly indicating that it is a
growing problem and and you know in the
circles that that I sort of pay
attention to you know there's this
movement called MIG tau which I'm know
you know about and of men who just have
decided what's the acronym breakout men
going their own way yeah and and I'm not
an expert on mgtow certainly and women
who be fighting for for for them to
think of me pronouncing on it I'm sure
but and there can be different reasons
and you know in the most in the broadest
definition I think it's just men saying
look I'm gonna focus my life around my
own pursuits and I'm not going to focus
my life around a woman and these men
tend to think that actually that's a
trap that a lot of men fall into is is
making everything about a woman and then
you can get you know really you can be
destroyed if you if the woman you happen
to focus your life around is crazy or
malevolent in some way she can destroy
her man by making a claim of abuse he
can find that the marriage he built the
home that he built the children that he
fathered all can be taken away from him
his life can be destroyed his business
can be taken away his reputation can be
ruined you know all of those things and
and so there's so much risk to the
young men in these involvement that a
lot of them are just deciding it's safer
not not you know not to risk anything
but I think there's a more general thing
too it's just you know it has to do with
that sense that everyday in some way
some of these men are beginning to feel
like their society just doesn't even
like them it's not even that they're
expendable which I think most men who
have studied the situation of men
throughout history would say that's
always been the case men have always
been yeah men are the ones that go to
war wife to protect the women so this
idea that all of human history is about
male power and privilege and and men
abusing women you know these men say
it's actually the exact opposite women
have always been the ones who are
precious in societies particularly in
Western society you know the chivalry
and everything else so you know that was
always the situation but expendability
is one thing but to be actually despised
by your just your society and told that
there's nothing good about you that even
your sacrifices aren't good enough and
yet you're still supposed to make the
sacrifices but they'll never you'll
never get any any kind of public
acknowledgement well that's why I always
say it's bowing forever yes what they
want
there's no penance right there is no
reclamation it's a it's a perpetual stay
there yeah you can never purge your
toxic masculinity no matter what you do
unless you die I guess you know rescuing
somebody but they figure out a way yeah
yeah I mean then that gets flipped over
and then that's an example of you know
patriarchal you know objectification of
women or something I mean it really is
like it's it's sick when you when you
listen to I mean I've read like lately
so many studies one about this was by a
feminist sociologist in sociology is
really I mean it's just crazy this was a
woman who has done work with the
homeless in Ontario and her whole shtick
was about how even amongst the homeless
certain ideas associated with hegemonic
masculinity could still be found in in
she interviewed various homeless men and
and you know the fact that the homeless
are overwhelmingly men right away you
know you shouldn't build yeah it points
to something doesn't it say something
about male privilege in our society that
you yeah you walk around the streets of
Ottawa you you almost never see a
homeless woman you see a lot of homeless
men and a lot of homeless white men as
well as homeless Inuit men many ways so
she had done this work with with
homeless men and and and she interviewed
them and yes she found that either
either they were lamenting the loss of
their hegemonic masculinity or they were
even so trying to assert their hegemonic
masculinity in various ways I mean it
was just it was truly crazy it had
nothing to do and and she actually
recommended at the end of the article
that programs working with these men
should perhaps you know help them to
whatever renounce their hegemonic
masculinity
there was another that's obviously their
number one yeah that's their number one
problem I mean it's just unbelievable
there was another article I read just
recently saying that that programs to
encourage men to be responsible fathers
this was I think these were American
programs I think she was studying that
such programs also reinforce patriarchal
because they reinforce this idea that
you know men have an important role to
play as fathers and she actually said
that this was a typical reassertion of
patriarchal thinking in that the
implicit assumption was that women that
mothers aren't sufficient for their
children so I mean she basically
outright said that that children don't
need fathers and fathers have no
necessary role in their children's lives
there's a lot of scientific evidence
that that's not that's not correct
exactly yeah that it's deeply damaging
to children do
sense that there's a movement now for
women and I think you'd probably be
including this but that young women that
are looking to get married and in their
you know late teens early 20s that they
want men back so I can only give an to
go to the example of this but I have a
lot of single straight female friends
that have their lives together have jobs
take care of themselves etc etc and we
are this like running joke that I don't
know virtually any straight men like
that I know a lot of gay guys that
seemingly have their lives together and
that are doing all of those things and
that's proud I don't know if you have
any thoughts on that it sort of kind of
decide bar but sort of interesting but
that there they want there to be men to
find and it's become like a running joke
for me like I don't know where they are
mm-hmm yeah well yeah um I think those
women are gonna have to start asking why
it is that they're not there and some of
the the reason I would say is precisely
that they're just not they're not
willing anymore to to be there because
it isn't possible I mean obviously there
are lots of men who are still willing to
take on responsibility and be the
achievers and all of that but I think
there has been sort of a general a lot
of men are disgusted with the paucity of
options that are that are offered to
them and they feel that you know it's
just there's there are too many risks
for them involved in doing the things
that they might have once wanted to do
and I think a lot of men are damaged too
from the decades of relentless
propaganda anti male propaganda how do
you think this is all connected to the
me to movement so I just want to be
clear on one thing so as we're taping
this because I'm on tour with Jordan at
the moment we are holding this video for
a little bit so the moment we're taping
this right now is the Cavanaugh hearings
and it just feels like everything that
usual
talked about here for the last 45 or so
minutes it seems like it's all being
unearthed now publicly in our political
arena that's why I think this is so much
more of a culture thing than a political
thing correctly yeah but can you relate
all of this to to me - well there's so
much about me - I mean I think partly
what me too represented for me anyway
like so many women have been told for so
many years that the whole history of our
culture is a history of male privilege
and so but in fact you know most women
at least I would say you know lower
middle class to upper middle class women
have had lives in which they've been
told from day one that they really
matter certainly that was my experience
I never you know I was born in 1964 so I
was going back to the I guess I was the
beneficiary of the second wave feminist
movement and certainly I always knew
that everybody in my life all of the
people at my school you know all the
coaches the mentors teachers they wanted
me to do well and I think a lot of women
have had that message you can do
whatever you want to do and and we
encourage you to go girl you know you
can be great you can be a rocket
scientist you can do something else you
know and and whatever you do you'll be
supported in it but at this so just to
be clear though as an anti-feminist now
second wave feminism back then pretty
good oh well that's a whole there's I
mean it had the the seeds of the deep
hatred of men in it I mean it was the
one that started rape culture and that
the history of women was a history of
you know male sexual violence and that
men kept women in check by by sexually
abusing them or by threatening them with
sexual some but when you said that you
that you were born out of that and that
things were okay well certainly things
were wonderful in the 1970s I mean my
argument would be that they would have
been pretty good anyway
you know I think ever since women got
the vote and men were happy to extend it
to them without any of the
responsibilities that men who had the
vote had always had to take on such as
military service and the willingness to
die for you're defending your country I
think everything every ever since that
happened basically men have shown
themselves pretty open to you know
admitting women into the professions and
encouraging women to you know to make
whatever kind of contribution they could
make to to our culture anyway so so yeah
there's a lot of things to talk about
there for sure but so basically what I
would say though is that women while the
same lot while being encouraged while
feeling that they an awful lot of
positive attention and energy are
focused on them at the same time they've
always been fed this this grievance
narrative you know that somehow in the
past it was all terrible for hundreds
and hundreds of years they've been
abused and so so we're getting to the
point now where having been fed that and
I really do think it is a outright lie
and the problem is too now that all of
history has been sort of rewritten and
so it's actually very difficult to find
out the reality of history because we
have it filtered through our popular
culture and things we think we know
about for instance women winning the
right to vote and the fact that there
are a whole bunch of men certainly in
Canada and Great Britain who couldn't
vote at the same time women were
campaigning for the right to vote almost
nobody knows that at all which men
couldn't vote at those poor men there
were there were property and wage
qualifications at the time so yeah there
were there were certain restrictions
many of the men who went and fought in
the First World War for instance the
young men they couldn't vote either so
so but we have this idea that for
centuries men could vote and basically
ran society and and women couldn't but
in fact that's not true this is a very
narrow window when most men could vote
and
women couldn't but anyway and in all
sorts of other ways we have these ideas
at women were the property of their
fathers or their husbands or that they
were you know abused that nobody
believed them that nobody cared if they
were raped that's that's the thing
that's coming out now I've heard a
number of high-profile female
commentators say in you know just up
until the recent past nobody believed a
woman if she said she'd been raped so
now we're gonna believe them now even if
that were true it wouldn't make sense
and it wouldn't be just obviously to
suddenly now just believe every time a
woman says that a man has done something
to her and we're gonna destroy that
man's career or we're gonna put him in
jail is that the most pervasive part of
this know that there is a growing
feeling amongst this crew that in order
to make an omelet you're gonna have to
break yes I think so that you're gonna
have to I mean because they're they're
quite literally I mean I see this again
from that class of blue check Twitter
you know feminists or whatever reporters
whatever they are yeah it's okay if a
couple innocent people get taken down
I've seen that over and over again yeah
it may be it's perfectly okay because of
the centuries and centuries of abuse and
yeah that's a crazy idea of retributive
justice punishing people as a class but
I think a lot of people a lot of well
both women and men who buy that
narrative are so whipped up in in
outrage over woman's supposed suffering
over the centuries that they're quite
willing to see some men suffer now I
mean I read an article maybe you saw it
too saying that you know Kavanagh should
not be that the nomination should be
withdrawn because although maybe we
shouldn't put men into prison just based
on a woman's unsubstantiated story from
36 years ago but hey come on you know
Supreme Court well all but five men in
the you know in the country don't get to
do that so big deal right you know it's
not and then that's certainly been the
attitude about the the tribunals that
have been put in place in American
universities to you know people would
say well there's no like there are no
standards
of justice here there's no opportunity
to cross-examine witnesses you're not
allowed to have a lawyer sometimes the
men weren't even allowed to know what
the charges against them work and they'd
always come out and say well but they're
not gonna be put in prison they're just
gonna be expelled from university right
you know as a pretty minor right well
that's why I think this topic is so
interesting cuz I'm not particularly I
don't particularly care about feminism
or any of these isms one where I want
everyone to be treated equally or at
least I want them I want the laws of a
nation to treat everyone equally and
then it's on you to figure out the rest
and sometimes there are bad people and
you have to go out and do it yourself
and figure it out okay but what now I
see happening and now I see why this
this sort of crazed feminism piece is so
directly related to free speech and the
issues that I really care about is the
way that we're this is connected to due
process now this is connected to yeah
we're gonna break a couple eggs and
we're actually going we're gonna
probably jail people and we're gonna
probably get people fired and all of
these things put out there so I do see
these these ties to much greater issues
and this in a weird way this is why a
lot of people I think Peter Bogosian
I've had on the show has talked about
how the gender studies really is ground
zero for this entire movement mm-hmm
right now yeah yeah absolutely and I've
seen this I mean this has been going on
in Canada for a number of years and it
does and gender studies is the ground
zero i think and part of it is this this
this idea that the you know things like
the presumption of innocence that those
really are structures designed
especially in the cases of you know
sexual assault law that that's designed
to protect bad men and therefore and
i've so i've read all sorts of articles
by by law students saying okay we know
what we know what rape trials look like
when presumption of innocence is the is
the default or is the standard what
would they look like if we started by
believing you know in that whole notion
of believing women as the as the
fundamental legal standard yeah it's
terrifying
what do you think are the best steps to
help people that are waking up so you
talked about how the you know you get
all these emails for men and you can
hopefully listen to them and that sort
of thing yeah but if they're there
because they're out there they're
watching this right now well I'm not
hopeful I mean I don't know I don't have
the answers I really don't I think that
we're we're really in a mess right now
if I wanted to say something really
inflammatory I what I would say is that
when I was a PhD student I used to read
newspapers from the 1870s 1880s and
1890s because that was my period that I
was working in and I wanted to see what
kinds of conversations were going on and
I did a feminist PhD I was interested in
in female journalists of the 1880s and
1890s and there were all sorts of
debates about gender relations as we
would call it now going on then and one
of them was a question of women's
political role you know to what extent
should women be politically involved in
really the late 19th century was a time
when because of advances in domestic
equipment and because of some
rudimentary birth control measures when
more women were able to make a
contribution at the public level in a
way they'd never really been able to
unless I'd been single but so there were
all these debates and you know most men
were pretty enthusiastic about the idea
of women becoming more publically
involved and there was very much a sense
that women would women brought a certain
kind of morality that women were
superior morally than men and we still
see that now I think you know the whole
idea that women don't lie about things
you know about rape or about various
other things that the women can end war
women can negotiate better than men all
that you know that's all Hillary ties
voted for a lot of wars yeah well that's
true but you know it's still the idea
that women have something in them that
you know is is perhaps morally superior
or gives them certain qualities that men
don't have still they're so
very much that and but the the the
anti-feminist position at the time said
it it's it's dangerous women are too
emotional
women are less rational than men women
can't take per they personalize
everything so they're not able to sort
of separate themselves and you know make
decisions that you know in an objective
unbiased manner and give that kind of
thing and you know this was related to
women's biology and various things and I
remember I used to laugh and think how
ridiculous I was and yet I have to say
that over the last ten years as I have
seen I mean because me to which claims
it's this new conversation it isn't
really new I mean if this has been going
on at least since Anita Hill and
Clarence Thomas and you know certainly
throughout the 1990s following Anita
Hills charges against Thomas there was a
lot of discussion about sexual
harassment in the workplace and what
we're gonna do about it a lot of
legislation brought in a lot of innocent
men
you know disciplined or fired from their
jobs as a result of various claims women
made that they've been made to feel
uncomfortable or you know whatever it
happened to be and so so this has been
going on for a long time I think and I
have to say that I it makes me wonder
sometimes whether those anti feminists
from the late 19th century weren't right
that what is it about this mass movement
so angry this movement of vengeance that
is starting to make these completely
irrational claims about how we should
proceed who we should believe why why it
doesn't matter that we suspend basic
principles of presumption of innocence
and due process how can it be this is
actually being taken seriously in our
public culture and I mean I don't know
but I do have to wonder whether the
presence of women isn't having some kind
of really Dilla Terius effect on our
public conversations about these things
that was only if you wanted to end
yeah I've really thoroughly enjoyed this
I mean it's it's such an interesting
topic because it hits on so many of the
things that I that I care about I
suspect we will do this again well thank
you very much yeah thanks for coming in
and for more on Janice you can follow
her on twitter at janice via mango
[Music]